hello youtube and welcome to part 11 of
let's play amnesia the Dark Descent now
we left off I just discovered him I
think of drowning some poor guy
but whatever merry drawbridge ha all
right
oh use my weight crush the bridge down
[Music]
ha ha move Daniel yeah all right who's
the best I am NOT you Daniel you sure no
not again no oh really using my orb
Alexander first eternal its power unto
us yeah in a sec tall overlaid with blue
fiery light and I could feel the same
things I felt in the dark chamber in
Algeria it was like standing in a mad
world pool of impressions are here when
there hasn't terrifying but Alexander
kept calm and wielded strange tools of
science in order to tame the store of
science and shortly the blue light was
stained by strains of red and the walls
burst with 15 tissue resonating with the
scene yeah Alexander quickly covered the
orb in some cloth and the unspeakable
thing vanished yeah that's bad the orb
shadow is closer than Alex
thought yeah he said I should prepare
for a warding ritual tomorrow I'm not
sure what he expects but I have a bad
feeling about this oh you're just
starting to get a bad feeling
I gotta stop using though I've got 26
tender boxes yeah oh hello
ha yarr
[Music]
I'm not afraid it's too dark and scary
about that huh well who's that
no no come on this down down oh damn you
chain aah
I'm gonna get you I'm gonna get you yes
three points oh yeah who's smart I'm
smart yeah yeah all right
let's go yep and the plank a plank
Oh five bucks says that's gonna break on
my way back I'm I'll be dunked in the
water and then there's gonna be water
misers everywhere imma be sad 18:39 it
is still early
and Alexander is busy preparing for the
ritual later today it's gonna be bad
seeing if this works huh makes me
question why oh I wonder what does he
stand to gain everything I realize he is
curious about it all but surely there
must be more no it's just the or foolish
he will attempt to tame the power of the
yes I must admit that yesterday when
Alexander flooded the inner sanctum with
blue light I realized we had but graced
the orbs true potential or you feel it
might turn out to be more than escaping
a creeping shadow really it might be the
beginning of something truly
extraordinary
well it wouldn't be a good story
otherwise alright let's do this last one
all the lights are going to go out on
yep uh-huh
all right here we go crack smell okay
okay I can deal with that that's cool I
like that but no kidding won't budge
that's a legitimate it won't budge other
doors where I've gotten that I've kind
of gone
I could probably shoulder my way into
this thing oh no this is gonna break ah
right still no water monsters yep I'm
good
I don't wanna okay all right good okay
did I do everything did I get everything
all right I'm okay all right Oh
oh god I haven't seen a monster in a
while I know that's on purpose
[Music]
Wow aren't you down solve you like every
other problem in this place it's world
rock at you I'm a laugh of that if that
actually fixes it no actually I'm not
even gonna laugh I'm not even gonna be
surprised
cuz so far that's been the answer to
everything
throw a rock at it
right there's my rock totally calling
this
and like magic buggers yep I knew it
roller rock at it oh [ __ ]
the morgue nothing ever good happens at
a morgue
ah do you see Dan you know Oh has it
what no it hasn't
no it's like this
right cuz I need some peace yes let's
wait to just down the corridor the
morgue dog Daniel you and literally
[ __ ] you murdering ass okay alright
let's get this over with
I need to use these damn tinderboxes
who's there yeah dead guy
oh do I have to do this breathing shut
up do you hear me oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh I'm sorry about this oh sorry that's
not do anything I just showing some very
disturbing psychological insight into my
mind right dead brats
oh that's that's lovely pile of bodies
always good
are you pointing at something something
new nope just bodies it's creepy
why why are there so many dead yeah
three bucks
ah see you Laden on annum oh yes he is
oh not be able to pass the gate
love you love Daniel tell me you do yep
yep yeah you do toes in you Oh bodies
why do you just have the bodies laying
about disgusting
ba-ba-ba-ba prisoners die contaminated
vit a don't know what that means
tinderbox
oh now I got bones instead of Bob no one
can help you scratches on the walls yeah
yeah one thing I do love like about this
game more than anything I mean the
atmosphere is great at all and I'm
having a blast the sound the audio like
really sells it I just wanted to say
that anyway back to the goofing off
I miss something I gotta cover - why do
I have a copy - what do I do with the
copper - OH
ha ha ha I got a syringe out of what how
does that make a syringe
there's a Lunger yeah whatever Oh what
do I do
plague what do I do with it
oh don't tell me that it's a day old
wonderful that's phenomenal why are they
still Boyce's hang out do something in
this pile of bodies a flower wow that
seems unlikely
that's enough dead penises for me oh did
I not click this injection of vaccinated
blood ah I suspected ah [ __ ] oh don't
tell me
yep I bet I've been the skull why the
skull Oh No
why did it break how could it break I
don't even care I don't care oh yeah
that makes sense what one now yes
ah what it why what Daniel you are so
beyond I don't even know I don't even
know I don't even know
Oh God no it's my chair need a chair
[Music]
shut up
[Music]
okay not my door yeah that's right back
off huh oh no no nothing like oh oh god
he sounds so fat oh he sounds fat yeah
back off take your woowoo somewhere else
like
gone yeah you better be cuz my visions
all good Daniel Daniel keep it together
Daniel give me together
immaterial whoa a little crazy there
okay
alright yeah injecting yourself with
that [ __ ] was probably a great idea okay
you're probably aids ten different ways
no now don't even know oh yeah I was
mentioning a flower in the loading
screen thing alright I gotta stop it
here thanks so much for watching guys
and I will see you in part 12 of amnesia
the Dark Descent thanks guys